can you objectively tell me which person
that you've opened for has the most
beautiful women in the crowd
damn would that be insulting to one I
mean it's pretty obvious I think the
[ __ ] it's Chris right like yeah Chris
Brown for sure Chris Brown for sure is
it crazy J Cole got those dudes that are
like [ __ ] die hard fans yeah gazing
in your eyes like just you know the
weirdos who are like 40 years old that
love lyrics you know
like you wouldn't want to go to a J
Cole's children you're not looking for
women there honestly
oh my God you know what I'm saying like
it's one of those places like but Chris
Brown Chris Brown yeah insane greatest
greatest performer you've ever seen I'd
agree yes
that I've seen like
in real life yes yeah outside of like
Michael Jackson I didn't see him before
yeah but just unreal Talent right unreal
bro he literally did like 20 spins in a
row on stage like
sweat flying everywhere yeah and he just
continued to spin yeah yeah and I was
like yo I don't even know how this guy
is continuing to spin yeah how do you
continue to spend did you see the
Michael Jackson tribute that they
actually didn't let him perform no no
yeah so he was videotaped it still like
online yeah so he was supposed to
perform I think that amas or something
like that yeah he's gonna do a Michael
Jackson tribute
like mixes probably like 10 different
songs together in some [ __ ] it's
incredible I've seen I've seen videos
there's videos of him doing like his in
his old tours he would do a Michael
Jackson song yeah and he'll do the whole
dance and everything like that and he's
just so but this blend was unbelievable
yeah yeah who was the first person to
hit you up that from your sketches you
were like oh [ __ ] this is popping oh
damn uh or was it like a moment where
you're like oh I [ __ ] made it
damn oh
I think puff puff hit me up and I was
pretty amazed like damn because I used
to watch all his uh all his like
motivational [ __ ] that he would post so
I would like always rip all his
motivational videos off his page and
like keep him in my phone and look at
him in the morning go work out like
be motivated and then not give a [ __ ]
hour later but yeah yeah you know what
I'm saying but like I really was like he
was one of those dudes that like I don't
know I just so when he hit me up or
whoever did me from his place we got
like 20 people that run this page but um
yeah and then when I met him in person
it was just like damn like yo you really
know who the [ __ ] I am yeah I really was
motivated by you yeah so I think he was
one of those early ones too you still
get nervous when you like meet a big
celebrity like if you meet Drake or
something for the first time
um
not not as much as a not yeah not as
much as I used to but I think the
respect level is still very high though
yeah I still you know when you talk to
somebody that you really looked up to
hell yeah so I can't really it's 50 50.
it just depends on who it is yeah yeah
it always depends on who it is you know
there's that video of a of Diddy closing
a deal on the phone yeah have you seen
that yeah and then I I actually ripped
that and said yeah I mean it's just my
favorite part of the video is he slams
the phone starts throwing [ __ ] around
nobody could stop me and then he
realized the phone might not be hung up
nah but Diddy's Diddy's just like Raw
Pure Energy Unstoppable flow of energy
you see him speak and it's like oh I can
see why he could walk into any room and
convince people that he would be the
person that could take their brand to
the next level yeah he doesn't give a
[ __ ] bro like even we I was around for a
couple days we were at his house we're
trying to shoot this um
this commercial and he's just one of
those people like he doesn't give a [ __ ]
bro like he's just constantly rip
running around yelling [ __ ] and like
I don't know he's he's honestly like
he's a one of one I've never seen nobody
else act like how he does oh really Bros
is it intimidating you know seems like
he got candy yeah I think uh his maid
service ladies are definitely [ __ ]
scared of him
really but he but no he's a great guy
like he just keeps everybody on
eggshells which works for him you know
I'm saying didn't work for everybody but
it works for him he's always heard that
same thing yeah everybody
to be performed 100 all the time all the
time like everybody around him he had me
perform oh okay in front of him and like
his like he was like 50 people in a room
and he had me coming there it was early
like when I was doing like skits and
stuff and he had me present like he's
like present like your funniest [ __ ]
tell us what you want to do and show us
like I think I had that's what could
have records was just just popping up it
was new and I had to like present all
this [ __ ] wait you performed in front of
him yeah it was kind of like a
performance slash me showing some of my
Clips on like a like uh like a board
kind of like how he just pulled up like
Eclipse yeah it was just me doing that
it was it was it was just like he's
known for that though yeah um I don't
really remember it was it was a long
time ago uh
I think I showed some of my could have
been records Clips okay but it wasn't
even all my good [ __ ] like I always show
them it was like early on [ __ ] and they
thought it was hilarious and then I said
a couple jokes
they thought that was funny too early on
the situation like I'm curious even
opening for Chris Brown when you first
started or whoever you started with you
you were doing stand-up so what do you
what do you do when you go out there I
was just telling stories yeah yeah yeah
yeah at the time yeah he's talking about
when I was on Chris Brown's tour yeah or
whoever was yeah when I was when I was
on Chris Brown I'm sure I did more it
could have been and when I was on J
Cole's tour I kind of did like a mixture
of like turning up the crowd and like
doing funny reactional [ __ ] and just
[ __ ] with the crowd like so I would
say funny [ __ ] to whatever City I'm in I
would like just kind of literally
understand a little bit Yeah Yeah like
kind of [ __ ] on the city but also like
talk to the people in the crowd talk
about whatever they yeah [ __ ] that they
know just to like understand we would
just play music there and do crowd work
yeah yeah hell yeah doing crowd work for
real so that's no materials just like
that's crazy yeah super charismatic yeah
great at skit sketches you're great at
stand up like [ __ ] how do you have
time to get good at so many different
things I'm still getting gonna stand up
I ain't fully mastered that that's
that's one of those that takes time man
it takes a lot takes time on stage yeah
but I want I want to conquer that [ __ ]
and I will you know what I'm saying but
I think I don't know man my mom had me
do all this [ __ ] that I was just
explaining all like karate [ __ ]
instruments piano
bass plan all this [ __ ] just all like I
was telling y'all like it's just all
added up and has become one big thing
but I look back at these videos and
seeing all the [ __ ] that I did it's like
damn bro all this [ __ ] is the reason why
I do what I do now hmm how'd you link
with J Cole in the first place uh
damn [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
um I think he reached out to me
uh
uh yeah one one of the two I think I
think he reached out to me and and told
me that he wanted he needed they needed
a host for the show
and he was that [ __ ] was a blessing for
real 21 Savage was on that tour too oh
[ __ ] did he remember you from the party
no
recollection at all
21. can you do something for me
that was crazy bro how do you come up
with the sketch ideas is it all you or
you have a team or yeah no I have a team
as well but I think we just live life
bro all just like how we come up with
how any other comment comes with comedy
I think you live life you go through
[ __ ] in real life scenarios are behind
all this [ __ ] that she's doing you know
what I'm saying